foreign
ERS podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims before we get started with
today's stream and yes we are reacting
to your assumptions about us today
quick announcement the drop is still on
you still have time there's about a week
left before we close the drop or once we
sell out more likely we will be closing
the drop as you can see it's very high
quality very nice very fresh and very
clean I'm wearing the two-piece it's the
sweater and then the oversized tee on
top of it so if you want to look fly
click the link in the description and
get some today inshallah I'm going to
bring up on hill so you can see what the
sweater looks like without the oversized
tee onhill get up here my man
look at that brother man looking fresh
nice and fresh hold up boy
man
you got hey hey
y'all got the the pockets
I didn't even know we had those what the
heck well listen the most practical
thing bro put something in there
you zip it up
you can run you can jump you can play
basketball dunk on someone cross someone
up and nothing it's not going anywhere
you take it out
hey popping in real quick
not gonna lie bro there have been many
times where I was like let me go on a
cold run it's cold outside let me go on
a nice run and my my phone's like
slipping out of my my pocket and all
that stuff very annoying this will solve
them yeah
show the links in the description
Insha'Allah
um
Canadian I know bro
and we literally grew up here in Canada
yeah yeah bro this guy's about to know
like four languages inshallah inshallah
annoying him he'll make it five
afterwards he'll be like four isn't
enough
um
doing good man how are you how about you
I'm the love bro a little bit of a
gloomy day today
yeah yeah it's always a gloomy day when
you don't let your beard fully grow in
you're not wrong about that one bro
s
all right so we're closing in on almost
150 viewers we will start the reacting
to your assumptions soon some of you
guys were hella off with the with the
assumptions I'm just gonna say this
though some of them were creepily on
point yeah I've seen that I was like
mm-hmm
yeah I um I didn't know it was like a
thing you know I I didn't know this was
like a thing people would say put in
your assumptions about us and it would
like become a meme people would put the
most outlandish stuff just to be funny
because I was looking at something I'm
like there is there is no way man there
is no way okay you guys will see what uh
what the lot of you produced
I don't know just remember you guys did
this
just know guys this is all you audacious
um
in case y'all didn't know this is on you
y'all did this
bro Rami literally just said that bro
you just said that too
okay but yo one more thing then
in case they didn't know
you guys did this all right let's let's
bring it up let's bring it up Bismillah
okay so first one says you spot my
my name wrong bro come on how you gonna
do that but it was a scrawny kid and
decided to change his lifestyle Rami was
good at Ball but lost his skills after
focusing on Islam more oh no looks like
he bullied kids at school but was kind
from the heart
let's start with the angel one bro I'm
actually interested about that
I know did you bully kids but you were
kind from the heart
I don't know man I don't know if it was
kind but I definitely did bully
yeah
it's not good Ramy what about yours
um it's weird because it's awfully it's
awfully right but it's not because I
started focusing on Islam I just
naturally you know I think it was my
time to to retire after my long and
fruitful basketball career
no doubt about that guys before we even
go on smash that like button right now
it only takes a second helps out the
algorithm let's go Bismillah Rami loves
I think they've had much dual dates yeah
you know it's it's
I think it is
no I just met Julie
bro I know you're not about to make a
big deal about how to pronounce a type
of dick I'm about to pull it up bro just
for you Bismillah fight was a nerd back
in high school okay that was true bro
Angel did you ever think a lot about
changing your name
yeah I did when I was younger because my
name is uh a Puerto Rican or just a
Spanish name bro and like our names are
like paragraphs kind of like the Arabic
names
and growing up in America bro like no
one could pronounce my name right so I
kept having to say like nicknames and
for the longest time I did I didn't want
to change my name
what about you
it that is true that is my favorite type
of date alhamdulillah let's go into the
next one Legend has it five doesn't take
off his cap even when he showers you
guys aren't wrong about that I've never
taken my cap off during a shower why
would I do that yeah that's why it's
always so clean exactly that makes no
sense bro come on like
I know this is true
I'm the type of guy to collect Pokemon
guys bro I had all of them and I played
the video games I had all of them too
and he got me the video game
hey oh yeah bro
this man done bought Pokemon on your
switch bro
there you go
on he'll probably spawns on Mars
sometimes when bored out of nowhere and
confuses some cockroaches bro you were
nice to never believed this but
sometimes I spawn in just random places
and I have no idea how I got there or
why I'm there in the first place
for real
fight has dealt with body dysphoria at
some point in his life prior to Fitness
on brows fat as hell growing up around
me does other people's homework for free
um
I'm reading Arnold's one bro
yo
that's accurate
bro who's writing this
they probably know man they probably had
like a Facebook or Myspace accounts yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um mine is technically true I guess uh
it's not like if you DM me saying hey
can you help me with this I'll do it for
you but like my sisters and brother you
know I do their homework a lot for them
in school I always liked it's weird I
always like doing homework Loki like it
was always fun and that's just you bro
what the hell is wrong with you bro yeah
that's that's what you think that's why
bro when I was when I was a kid I used
to find uh you know how we used to get
like homework passes yeah
bro I found like a whole stack of
homework passes and I started selling
them oh my God damn
that's the next level bro that's next
level
but it was definitely an boy in younger
days
that's that's wild bro I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna address that at all bro
somebody commented on that Xena
accusations I see or something like that
yeah I was like okay bro I don't know
but I don't think they meant it like
that yeah yeah but that's why I mean I
mean hopefully it's important that we we
maintain an Islamic etiquette even when
uh doing yes trends like that is that is
a very fair point
Anna listens to Joe Rogan on The Daily
what's up with that picture though
I didn't even notice that bro
is that you're gonna say anything about
that no no I don't
okay some of the podcasts be on point
though yeah Romy is Lebanese fight is
fit I know it's tall actually Romney is
the tallest one out of all three of us
you know he's the tallest one bro
mommy's like six eight
um close in a six eight and a half okay
um
are you tall
I don't know man
tall is that's this very subjective
relative question like tall as in what
tall compared to the average height
talk compared to other Puerto Ricans you
could be told like going like to China
or something but then you go to Iceland
and then you shoot
bro you remember when we went to Iceland
bro all the men were seven feet and all
the women were six feet that's crazy bro
all these old guys bro got you breaking
your neck looking up to them no I'm not
about it but yeah I'm I'm not Lebanese I
don't know if I look Lebanese but I'm
actually Palestinian
ethnicity review and and for fire bro
just look at his name like fire like
what do you like come on man that was a
given that's that's too easy I know it
was a Playboy back in the day before he
became a pray boy
wow
I like twist are you gonna address that
these these slanderers I don't think I
should reveal my pets
okay no that's good
over it there you go yo it seems like
people are really wondering uh how tall
I am I'm not actually six eight that was
a joke I'm six one alhamdulillah just
because people actually believed it for
a second so damn bro don't believe
anything we told them bro yeah but my
cousin is like six seven I don't know if
if either of you guys have seen them my
cousin's like which cousin which cousin
his name is Naseem I don't know if you
know I think we saw him we met him yeah
yeah
tall brother yeah though he was there
when way of life came over yeah yeah
yeah
Allah
fight's favorite Cuisine is Puerto Rican
wait but you mean Puerto Rican food or
you mean Puerto Rican like like Puerto
Rican women I did not really understand
that bro why would you why would you say
that wrong
literally like look at how the way they
put it five's favorite cuisine
bro why would why would Aisha be talking
about women think about that it's cool
I'm just playing bro I'm just but listen
listen listen now regardless of which
one she's talking about
I have no experience with Puerto Rican I
don't do Puerto Rican I've never tried
Puerto Rican in my life
I don't plan on unless angel can make
some good ass Puerto Rican food
maybe some uh platanos bro
you know I don't like plantains
why maybe I've just ever had good
plantains bro you want to change my mind
yeah I could change your mind bro I made
some for Rami and his family that was
five years bro yeah inshallah inshallah
Romy was deaf's popular in high school
because he because bro looks magnificent
okay well I won't lie I do look
magnificent alhamdulillah
but I wouldn't call myself popular and I
definitely didn't look this way in high
schools I was friends with everyone
alhamdulillah so it depends on what you
mean by the word
yeah I read that wrong yeah the sister's
asking uh or not asking about saying me
on her marching yeah from the same
collection in that collection in the
description so if you also want to match
if you also want a match zoom in on that
logo bro right there there you go hold
that for a sec
that's the one yeah
plain man
click the link get yours today inshallah
anho hates cheese and has never tried
sushi
I love cheese and I Love Sushi you know
so you guys are hell off with that one
five skips leg day
have you seen his legs in the shooter
podcast
man's got the neediest curves you'll see
man
harami is secretly buff
I mean Angel bro you got more workouts
in with Rami in the summer than me so
what do you think
you think
Romney's got
I only got some muscle but
he needs to put in more work he has the
frame bro yeah you definitely got the
genetics for like a very
proper aesthetic body told you this bro
yes it's true
um
that's all I'll say that's all you heard
it here first ladies and gentlemen next
one of ano's favorite Cuisines is
Mexican
nah I'm not really a fan of Mexican food
it's nice like Chipotle but that's like
chain Mexican food it's not probably
Mexican food
what do you think about this
you see that look really slow but then
when you try to race them
uh they modded the hell out of it yeah
um
abandoning a certain lifestyle
have we not all
yeah
what do you think Romy
yeah I mean I didn't really understand
it at first is he just saying that like
we abandoned something once we we you
know got guidance from Allah well
everyone did that but I think they're uh
they're alluding to a particular
lifestyle
like a wild Yahoo lifestyle I don't know
about that
um no I was I was never I was not that
like anything crazy growing up
alhamdulillah like I tried to be I
pretended to be but I was always a
normal kid to be honest I just wanted to
copy those around me and then I came to
Islam and I found that yo these guys
don't know what the heck they're doing
and uh we're gonna leave high school and
you know two years or a year or whatever
and uh and we're gonna die one day and
all that matters really is this you know
your religion mm-hmm
Savanna love bro
I'm not gonna comment on that
Rami never shaved off his beard this is
one of the things that my my wife hates
she's I was so Stern about my beard
never like trimming anything
um and then I found out I actually can
um so uh yeah
shaving when I was really young shaved
off yeah when I was really young before
I started practicing I think a few times
but after I started practicing I don't
think I've ever shaved it cleanly
um
did I hear that correctly your wife is
uh she hates you or she's absurd about
it because
she wants you to shame or she wanted you
to like let it
it just looked messy that's like like
the Stray hairs and that stuff you know
it looks you wanted a little bit more
kept than presentable yeah and she's
right about that you know I asked I
asked some people of knowledge and they
told me the same thing
you know trying to look fresh
yeah I think it looks wild bro
what about like the the Omar Suleiman
lineup you know the crisp like when it's
all done like every single day I love
listen but you personally wouldn't
I wouldn't do the lineup that's like
nah bro that was like old school like
little kid type things and I'm not
calling him a kid or anyone who does
this yeah a little kid but it's like I
don't know it's like when you when
you're trying to line it up so perfectly
and keep it real nice and short it's
like why bro and why are you trying so
hard you know you know there was uh one
of our our beloved Brothers bro that
joined us in Dubai you know the one I'm
talking about yeah brother lines it up
every three hours
look I love the beard like for Years bro
he's just it's always so clean Allah
presentable you know
Fighters Pakistani and married
man that's offensive is like far off
with that
you are
you are not true about about that
statement
I don't know if it's partially I don't
know if it's fully not true
I think Angel is a mean cook
um
I know is that true
nah sometimes I'll get lucky sometimes
I'll be lucky and I'll make something
I'm like
but then most times it's like yeah
my wife is a amazing cook man I love
this
bless you on her I mean I mean
I don't know just to clarify before they
come after me
just come on bro I'm not Pakistani just
shows who actually is OG day one t3m and
who's not yeah
oh they probably know and they're just
playing with you I feel like Anjo used
to be a very angry human being I don't
know why
you zoom in on the editor zoom in on
that look how
you could tell them that
I had actually had anger problems with
my entire life and um I say I still have
anger problems
but I've learned to control it you know
run me inside they both mentioned this
word I'm like that that true individual
who has a short fuse
but I've actually like I do a pretty
good job alhamdulillah I'm like oh you
came a long way bro I think I knew you
more
from jahelia than after you were Muslim
or it's like probably closing out on 50
50 maybe not
but most of my experience with you
pre-islam
[Music]
and I don't particularly think the anger
went away I think you just you're much
better at controlling it
yeah that's what Islam does to people
I uh also I wanna I wanna pull up a
comment really quickly just because
I really I thought it was funny David
wood and young Don wanted 2v2 man and
Romney I know they don't they don't know
that's definitely a joke I would love to
but I don't think is like a Duo kind of
person I think he'd want to do like a
2V1 you know what I mean yeah he doesn't
do group debates he told us yeah that
would be sick though yeah he's he's the
one you asked coach to submit and then
you just call us bro you let them handle
business
next
brother Romney is an introvert that's
how she that's actually very true I
always I always tried to be like half
half like yeah but you can't you have to
have a period in which you rest and it's
either with people or without people for
me it's always about people
um
it doesn't always make you introvert bro
introvert just means you rather be by
yourself than be with other people
yeah of course bro I mean I couldn't I
could have answered the question for you
yeah I lived with you for a little bit
you know just a little bit yeah and that
was fun times bro
you guys don't really talk much outside
of your Channel
slander bro
depends on on what you mean by talk we
definitely talk like every single day
outside the Channel 100
um but like talk talk like just calling
each other like hey how you doing how's
Fred like but we don't really do this
all the time it's like very random that
we do this yeah it's not scheduled like
our live streams yeah yeah we'll take
that as a reminder
okay
assumptions for the love diminishing
marginal utility rationality independent
what the hell is this guy talking about
bro I've never heard of this man what
the is he just like doing his homework
on screen
of diminishing marginal utility can you
can somebody Google that around me can
you Google what the hell somebody in the
chat comment down below what is the law
of diminishing marginal utility let us
know no no I actually want to know man
because like it sounds like it would be
something like really on point but at
the same time like whoever made this
what the hell are they thinking why
would they like over complicated so much
so where you're looking at it and you
have no idea what it is it's actually
referring to
yeah I uh I got it right here I'm gonna
pull it up for a second someone with
microeconomics microeconomics can you
guys see it
yeah let me let me put it in the
full screen give me one second there you
go okay
yeah yeah I got you one second
there you go
all right so yeah the marginal sorry
yeah the marginal utility of a good
service that declines more declined us
more if it's consumed by an individual
okay so basically the more you put it
out
um
the the more it's marginal utility right
lines
you know what I'm dying bro I'm
imagining somebody just entering the
stream right now and like what the hell
are the three Muslims talking about
the marginal utility of a good or
service declines as more of it it is
consumed by an
individuality though what is the
definition of utility here that's the
thing they they didn't really say
let me see bro utility is just utility
bro come on
the benefit again from consuming
something
hello man I bless you guys and all of
yours I mean
yeah it's basically the more someone
uses something the less they want to use
it because the benefit decreases over
time bro why couldn't they just put it
like this
and why do they say in the first place
like are they assuming that about us
like that's a bit offensive not gonna
lie
I don't know I don't I'm so confused
what was the question again that's the
thing with business students bro y'all
would literally pay someone to learn
random ass stuff you can learn online
then actually go get real world business
experience
come on yes I'm about to generalize all
Ecom Finance
and I'm still confused
well let's move on let's move on
Andrew Tate will be on the podcast for
sure
is bro what is the name the spelling's
getting worse bro is what faeed's idea
to start first of all how does that even
make sense is what fights idea to start
three Muslims
no it's Allah's plan
know that
on his low-key Giga Chad what the hell
does this mean bro give each other this
is just like oh you you like this one
dude that looks completely enhanced in
every single picture
yeah yeah basically
yeah
he's high key
damn I don't know whether that's a
compliment or an offense bro
I think it's a compliment yeah man stood
up okay
um next fight wasn't into fitness when
young and was bullied into it that was
actually how I started Fitness listen
I'm about to say something right now and
the reason that I got into fitness was
my dad
your dad bullied you bro you didn't
bully me but I was getting fat as hell
bro eating all these Oreos and Doritos
and just eating whatever I wanted Pizza
bro Subway
huh
I said the life the life bro listen and
that's the thing with getting fat bro
you start eating like a pig and you
don't realize because it doesn't catch
up to you right away and before you know
it a few months later you look back
you're like how the hell did I get like
this bro so I was five foot four and 210
pounds bro
five foot four that's bro that's there's
something wrong with that bro that's all
I'm saying and parents didn't say
anything bro for all those years one day
randomly my dad just looked at me mailed
a blessing for this
I I'm not even gonna listen I'm not even
gonna mention what he said bro but he
said something just it wasn't even like
an insult it wasn't even an attack it
was just like matter of fact you know
and it was just like just said it and
passing bro he probably didn't even
notice anything bro I went to my room
and I started crying bro and that was
the last day bro
that's all I'm gonna say yeah
may Allah bless him I mean
he's just three guys that people make an
impact on the wood and bringing everyone
inshallah may Allah
we're here to conquer we're not here
I think the three of you plan to go to
Dubai to interview Andrew Tate but ended
up interviewing shooter
you know what actually subhanallah so
firstly that is true secondly uh I'm I'm
not happy it happened but I'm like it's
hard to say like I'm actually Loki happy
it happened obviously we wanted to talk
to brother Andrew but I can't beat this
bro shooter is such an amazing guy it
was such an amazing interview
bro let's let's not get it twisted even
if we would have gone initially to
interview Andrew Tate and he was
we would have still interviewed
Sartorius especially as a revert yeah
yeah come on now yeah Miller blessed
Jewel bro I love what I mean they were
brother bro from the Middle East right
now
and best podcast those four guys
yeah for real next
fight can bench Squat and deadlift the
most out of all three
probably
um how much do you did this bro
my I don't deadlift now because of my
back I already told you but when you did
my Peak was 4 15.
I was there like
three plates and like a 25 no or that's
four plates and a five on each side
how about you
I don't know man the the most I ever did
when I was like
just testing stuff out I had three
plates for reps yeah I never actually
max out on deadly because
well you know you hear the story I think
that was my like three rub knocks or two
rep max tour Max martial laws
but my squad's terrible bro we don't
talk about my squat I hate squat
inshallah
[Music]
oh no it was a type to sleep throughout
exams
were you about to have a list right
there
maybe bro just for you oh yeah sleep
Flip Flip
I mean bro you do like to sleep bro I'm
not gonna lie anytime listen I'm not
about to expose anything but whenever I
travel with Angel bro he needs his sleep
I'm out here like bro let's go he's like
bro let's just sleep until this time I'm
like come on bro bro quit playing you
know you need to sleep too
I do bro but not as much as you
so actually this is very true I need a
lot of sleep
but when I get a lot of sleep I function
very well you do you do you do you're
very mentally present
Ramy what about you you think you need a
lot of sleep or about the average
I think I'm I'm good getting sometimes
I'm good getting just five hours of
sleep but eventually it catches up to me
and I need a full a full hour exactly
Hour full cycle yeah well that's why
when Jewel was telling us about like the
Tates and how they're like they're up
for all this time and they only sleep
like a few hours and then he's saying
that he had to like adapt to that and
I'm just sitting on here like how the
hell do you adapt to this Jewel
something I feel like yeah no but I feel
like if I I can go several days or
getting a few hours but then after a
while I'm just like damn bro
yeah but but there's something I noticed
myself that that that while it takes for
you to burn out it gets longer and
longer and longer over time yeah okay
that's true okay
I guess what you're you're saying is a
quit making excuses basically yeah yeah
do you want me to put it next
five's GPA was probably a 4.0 in college
uh you're back in uni it was like 3.9
something it was like 3.94
I don't even remember man honestly it's
been a while bro
alhamdulillah
I think Rami is a Hafiz I wish man
that's first
assuming that about me that's that's a
beautiful assumption I wish it was true
but I'm not Insha'Allah one day
um
brother got married at a young age
I plead the fifth yeah boy don't know
yeah
pineapple goes in Pizza
um so I don't know about in pizza I like
it on Pizza what do you guys think in
Pizza is it good
um no how is that an assumption about us
yo pull up the Urban Dictionary see if
there's like reference to like some
dirty joke
I think that's exactly what we're not
going to do that isn't that right
[Laughter]
Bud was a chubby kid yes come on get
with the program
harami was picked on in school
actually actually never there was a time
where like I I thought I was being
bullied back in like gray like one or
two but it wasn't bullying like it
wasn't even close to it so yeah never
alhamdulillah
yo I just kind of want to like
say this because I didn't say before I
wasn't that bad of a bully all right
I was very kind bully
I was mean but I was nice at the same
time this is clear that up
subhanallah the fact that you have to
clarify that really speaks volumes bro
everyone or your clear pure attention
[Music]
fire is a productive dude he hits the
gym pray as soon as the Adan is
completed skin care
first of all I was going to say Allah
make me as you see me but skin care
what's wrong with skincare bro why are
you hitting on skincare
I don't do no skincare
water bro we'll do that's it
I don't even put lotion I haven't put
lotion on in like 15 years damn Marshall
uh whenever we touch you this
no you bro cause I don't even know you
15 years ago
but may Allah bless you regardless
I mean actually yo I have to pause this
but I mean why are you getting tight bro
at the whole skincare thing you do
skincare
per se there is one thing I used and bro
it is like it is amazing I don't know
what it does but it does what is it what
is it
no no I I my wife gave it to me off the
hospital just called but itself is it
from the ordinary
probably I think so yeah
everyone had that face
everyone had that face bro I had a I had
a whole four month skincare phase bro
when I was in high school or like in the
high school
uni
I think encourage me if I'm wrong maybe
y'all have had this airport at one point
but I feel like every guy has had the
the phase of skin care in terms of like
the acne products like proactive and uh
what's the other one called Neutrogena
yeah and it's like you're cleaning your
pores and stuff like that the moisture
the cleansers the cleansers yeah you
come to find out that stuff is worse for
your skin than just water horrible wrong
yeah big Pharma strikes again
I think it is the kind of guy who
have a story for any situation to tell
you about his wisdom
um not really man I
I'm still young I don't have that much
wisdom sometimes
you got wisdom
[Music]
everyone needs an animal in his life oh
no bro did I literally just call you
like a night ago or two nights ago I was
like bro
I'm so glad I have you in my life
I meant it bro alhamdulillah
around me bro I'm so glad I have YouTube
wrong
I wish
I love you guys as well Rami is
an Imam I um I actually am I'm the Imam
of my house alhamdulillah
um other than that no like in a measure
or whatever no legs
not yet
did fire grew up in a Muslim family yes
alhamdulillah I grew up in a
in a nice Bengali Muslim family
also probably forgetting his name right
you spelled it correctly yeah guys come
on comment down below hashtag no Hindus
yeah cause some people think bro I was a
Hindu and I reverted bro we've been
getting a lot of those comments
yo this is completely random but I think
it's so be fitting because I mean we're
just doing a random string so y'all
remember that one time we had done the
podcast with Hamza sauces yeah which one
and then as soon as we get I don't
remember we as soon as we got done with
the podcast we were like talking with
him just like after the stream and I was
cutting up some watermelon as we were
talking that but we put that on patreon
or only fans it was only like exclusive
yeah yeah
[Music]
guys we got banned from patreon isn't
that crazy
I think it was specifically for that
video
I shouldn't have cut the watermelon like
that bro I told you
foreign
maybe the pineapple that they wanted to
put in the pizza
bless you my brother
let's go with it no it's not we've never
had only fans I was just uh no that was
a joke guys I don't want I don't want
look look at this bro people already
come on
I mean you said it you got to clarify
man listen there was one time on my
personal channel the the YouTube channel
where I had joked around about the only
fans and I had guys hitting me up saying
like oh do you really have the only fans
if you do like uh send me the link and
I'll sign up I'm like
[Music]
we are outwardly and clearly condemn
only fans it's disgusting in uh industry
the whole industry discussing the
platform disgusting everyone men and
women should be modest you should lower
your gauge cover yourself you should
save yourself for your price partner
inshallah you yourself should be a pie
man or a woman and submit to Allah this
degeneracy is killing Society
I mean I mean I mean Miller Grant those
Pious paintings in life with quickness
Allah I mean yes oh no I mean what do
you mean yes
whose authority are you saying this
yo
like this chain of narration yeah let's
let's ask the brothers
what
is Osman captain
me no no you're not mean yeah no you
know what I mean
because in some of the videos bro you
just be real stoked you don't have like
any emotion
and that probably like resembles for
some people
um
being mean she tripping bro
and Omi is someone who controls his
anger in a beautiful way
I try my best way sometimes I get pretty
mad
um
but uh you know actually I was just
telling the guys before we started the
stream something kind of came up
yesterday it got me thinking about death
and um
it's about a lot it really just put me
in a place where I realized I just want
to be the best person I can be in all
circumstances you know if I'm angry
really mad I want to do my best
inshallah to control it because I'm 22.
if I live the average lifespan I'll live
another what 63 years or something like
that that's not a long time man I'm
gonna die very soon and uh
alhamdulillah you know he's got to be
the best person you've got to impact
people positively inshallah
I'm the lover I'm loving of this comment
uh
uh mellow forgive you for that one
I mean a lot I've actually gotten this a
lot
I am
isn't that the uh the Spider-Man actor
yeah yeah bro The Amazing Spider-Man
yeah yeah I should have bro I should
have been the the Muslim Spiderman
inshallah one day you know if Marvel
fixes their ways inshaallah
can each of the brothers your beautiful
eye of the corner and they've come
across recently
verse 152 remember me I will remember
you
foreign
I saw a video and I was planning on
reacting to this on my channel but I saw
a video of Hassan talking about
Andrew Tate and how he's a fake Muslim
and all that stuff
and Hassan is someone who I as far as I
know he claims to be a Muslim at the
very least and it just got me thinking
about Quran
um
that indeed the Believers are about
brothers and then he says so make peace
with your brothers and we see like you
know some of these people can be Muslim
Andrew takes a Muslim now yeah and he
says he's accepted Islam they have
almost hatred for the guy you know
they're insulting him they're beefing
with him and it's like Allah says so
make peace with your brothers
consciousness of God so that you can
achieve his Mercy don't you want that
isn't that what you want in life
you know someone wrote this is that true
I don't know as far as I know he claims
to be a Muslim he says
his beliefs I think there are some
things he says that are off but let's
let's not claim anything crazy inshallah
let's talk to the brother first
inshallah inshallah
each other
next
Arnold convention 185 pounds
that is facts bro Allah Mubarak he
Ventures to 225 for reps
if I convinced 225 yes
easy
Romney can bench 130. it's always come
on that's so easy
rhyming every time I went to the gym I
think the chest was like the biggest
muscle group he kept working out yeah
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely I'm a
little more Diversified now
alhamdulillah but uh that was that was a
big Focus for me
we'll go to the gym like the third day
in a row I'm like bro I'm gonna do like
uh some like shoulders and some back
what are you gonna do he's like I'm
gonna do chest I'm gonna do Chester
yesterday
he's like yeah yeah but you know I don't
feel like I got a good enough workout
you know all right all right bro that's
exactly how he said it too
um
I love hitting just within Omi
next
Anno has three wives
and just one alhamdulillah
you don't need three when you got the
one bro okay so look at this look at
this I know I tell a lot of stuff back
in the past I know this I know this
disclaimer uh but I'm not gonna be one
of those guys that's like trying to
Advocate uh oh only get one way oh I
have like three four or two Watts is
more so like you have to praise to God
and
just be right with Allah you know like
if if you it's like Allah Quran if you
can get more than one and you can be
like treat them exactly the same and be
proper with all of them
okay like go ahead you have the ability
to do so but if you can't do this then
don't do this you just have one and if
you can't even do that with one that
don't have any
alone
I got married at the same time that
Romney got married and that's all it was
actually pretty crazy it was pretty
crazy that like
we Allah made it this way so where both
of us got made at the same exact time
foreign
favorite food is a thousand percent
biryani Amani I think you are a thousand
percent wrong about that that's that's
all I'm gonna say
Biryani I like Biryani it's not bad my
mom makes really good Biryani I'm the
little bless her but nothing not my
favorite I love your mom's cooking
mom you hear that she's always watching
the podcast till this day bro she never
missed a single video same with my dad
that's proper those like real true
supporters bro subhanallah
I mean forever
thank you
no alhamdulillah I also have one wife
alhamdulillah
[Music]
youth
hell no
Angel is Mexican
he doesn't like when you call him that
watch your mouth yeah he actually gets
married
I don't even get treated by that I just
play around because it's so funny in
like people's reactions you know yo I'm
playing I'm playing I didn't mean it
like that
yeah you did that to my mom you freaking
I remember that yo can you can you say
the story bro
but just story time yeah so we all want
me to say this okay
if I miss anything let me know so we all
went to Walmart
and uh we kind of like split up angel
went to grab his stuff I want to grab my
stuff my mom went to grab her stuff and
then um in the aisles my mom runs into
Angel and she wants to like know what to
make for dinner and stuff so she's like
she said something about like you like
tacos it's like it's like you know your
food or something like that no no no no
no no no bro let me let me let me
correctly correct it so we're in Walmart
you got that park right we did split a
ways and as I was like getting my stuff
I'm like really focused I get like hyper
focused when I'm doing things am I hyper
focusing like looking for like the best
bread to choose the one that has like
the best nutrients if there is one and
as I'm like looking I hear like my name
like in the background like I'm here I'm
like I I just ignored it I was still
focused on this like looking for the
ingredients and then I heard it again
like I had I'm only looking around I see
your mom and she's like next to burritos
and she's like oh should I get the the
white ones or the brown ones and I'm
like
uh-huh whichever one's fine like it
doesn't matter she's like oh but but
which one do you guys eat I'm like uh
let's just do white you know any color
so let's do white you guys bro I'm
thinking I'm thinking to my mom like you
guys like what do you mean here and
um you know I'm thinking like ah you
guys like all of us you know like all of
us are gonna eat burritos or tacos
together and we get to the house bro and
I'm like helping you guys like put
everything away
and at one point
I think she was like oh so like how do
you guys how do you guys make your your
tacos your burritos I'm like
uh hold on I gotta address like what do
you mean like you guys like oh like in
in Mexico like how do you guys make it
I'm like oh no no no no
uh
what do you mean you people
yeah yeah bro hey go back to your
country got me feeling like Donald Trump
for a second bro
man
no this was last summer this wasn't this
Ramadan yeah yeah that was last summer
yeah don't be out of pocket bro during
during Ramadan
Rami for sure likes anime
actually it depends yeah obviously yeah
yeah it depends on anime also I don't I
I don't I I'm not watching right now I
don't know if it's Halal or Haram yet I
generally don't know uh or if it depends
on the the type but um
all right
Puerto Rico
on her legs Bad Bunny
what no no remove that remove that
comment remove that no Bad Bunny is uh
the rapper another rapper
I knew you were thinking of something
dirty bro
s
trying to cover that up for me boy yeah
but it's uh Bad Bunny is a rapper he's a
Puerto Rican rapper I see I see oh okay
okay I don't listen to music though so I
can't really tell you oh yeah
um
it's blessed through it boy we got we
got not much time left let's just do
like yes or no it's really fast then
okay five house girls
next
I bet on Hill eats red meat
I read that it's so wrong bro but yes I
do even
looks like he goes to the gym every day
alhamdulillah you are right sister
who is he Asma again with this who are
you talking are you clearly talking
about um
next skip skip
[Music]
it seems like he's really funny behind
the camera but tries to maintain a
serious face nope
that's so true what do you mean I
thought fight is African nope
Muslim Lantern's twin you know who she
talking about yeah yeah close but no
close but no no thanks we don't want
what you saw Andrew Garfield's twins
Romney is not out of wrong I am autop
I'm Palestinian
um
I think Angel doesn't have or watch tick
tock
you are correct
I know it was a popular boy in school
yes alhamdulillah
one of you guys been in a lot of fights
back in the day it wasn't me
no comments
yeah yeah come on I'm not trying to
review the thing I think five's favorite
clothing brand is Tommy Hilfiger nope
it's actually get
Gap I don't think I've been a gap in
since I was a kid bro I don't um I know
secretly S3 was but he is too humble to
let us know come on bro why you so
humble why you put the heart cut this
fake false higher bro Yusuf why you
putting a heart bro
I think romy's favorite subject in
school was social studies bracket
history no no no there is um there is
one course challenging change in society
I like that and I also actually like
math believe it or not
I don't know your parents call you Angel
at home
no
they call me by my real name oh no it's
a secret out of
Atlanta's best man in Puerto Rican as
far as I know
free Philistine guys make the offer for
Palestine right now this is every
Ramadan bro stuck for Allah
dear judgment they'll be dealt with but
come on we gotta unite make our duas the
walls can change the fate of the world
brother anho is the funny one in the
group
I think we're all funny to be honest
anho was the type of kid in school to
always sleep in class
you get no wrong bro our energy me you
Rami and wahab bro that was funny that
was so funny bro there's things we can't
even say well man that was oh I still
laugh every time I look back to those
times it was a fun time wow bro we miss
you
uh
the one stream we mentioned him he
doesn't make it and
give us tuition bro God bless him
Rami was not always into Islam yeah
foreign
just to intimidate people since he's
skinny and short
you're correct what the heck come on
damn
he also sent you 1.99 for a protein
because you're skinny and short
[Music]
from the UK you guys have strengthened
my faith when I had doubts previously
wanted to ask you or ask what you
studied and your current jobs as well as
a pod
all right
I um I studied electrical techniques I
was actually going to be an electrician
then I switched kind of like to the
the computer engineering computer uh
programming that kind of field
um right now I work
for a
a lead generator Company lead generation
company for solar and Roofing and and
different different uh Industries
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah I studied in
uh pre-med and then studied medicine and
now I'm taking a little bit of a break
in the middle of it to uh work on and
take care of some stuff alhamdulillah
the sake of Allah honored by you
yeah you didn't say where your job was
my job I'm a consultant
and I'm a co-partner in the Oma Academy
[Music]
so for myself I studied you studied the
game
yes
I studied
uh exercise science
so like Kinesiology Anatomy uh something
like this you know for like working out
Sports all that but then I only did that
for
a few years and got into the whole
YouTube game
got into the Consulting game
and then inshaallah
now
what we are trying to do myself Fayed
Rami and this other brother that we are
with and then multiple other people that
we're partnering with as well is we're
creating a platform
that's specifically for the Muslim man
so that he can level up to the best of
his ability and we made this
particularly because I I had this idea
and it was all alone it's not me when I
see me it was all love but the idea was
that
it's like
I went through all this in my life to
grow and I didn't have these examples I
didn't have these Role Models I didn't
have this guidance I didn't have these
sources of information where I could
properly grow and level up so for me it
took
it took almost like 10 years of
self-improvement to get to where I'm at
but had I had the proper instructors a
proper resources
and the guidance I feel like all of that
could have been condensed into like one
year
you know so what we're trying to do with
this platform is we're trying to provide
that for every single Muslim man so that
they can become the man that Allah
intended for them to be and inshallah
that will be our job from here on now it
will replace everything else that we're
doing except for the podcast is this
this they go hand in hand for life
has a daughter
I actually do she's right there under
the desk right now alhamdulillah
next Mahmoud writes
salaam alaikum Brothers thanks brother
Angel for responding free Philistine uh
enough is enough I mean bro all right
let's get back to it
next
fight was embarrassed of being Bengali
as a kid but learned to appreciate it
that's facts that is facts
he listened one too many times me
telling people I'm from Bangladesh and
they're like oh is that in India and
then eventually I just started saying
eyebrow I'm just Indians
stuck for them my parents are gonna hear
that right now they're gonna be like
what
but this was true you sounded so upset
bro yeah
I'm the law oh they talk about Romy for
this for sure yes Romney is the king of
Internet
let's skip this inshallah
yeah
Juan
Angel probably likes to meditate a lot
you know I don't I don't meditate you as
much as I used to
I do praying more now I'm recording but
meditation is nice the the simple kind
from the
father had eye surgery nope
from the father type of Dude to laugh
and then become serious .02 seconds
later
that's funny
it's very correct too anho seems like an
introvert
I can't even tell you what I am
we'll let you know when we find out yeah
uh Romy can you read this bro it gives
me the freaking paragraph but okay if I
look like he orders black coffee only to
stare into the cup deep in thought for
like an hour before he leaves the shop
without drinking because he doesn't like
coffee especially not black on her looks
like he definitely enjoys reading the
odd trash fictional novel but also some
old classics Dickens Maybe or I mean it
looks like he burns microwave popcorn
but takes pride in scrambling eggs that
was actually true for me
I started putting it on the like the
sensor mode in the microwave for popcorn
I don't I don't do I don't do that
coffee thing that you mentioned bro when
I was cutting
in 2018 I think that was my most recent
cut before this current one I used to
take a spoon of ground coffee and I
would just eat it bro I literally just
put that spoon of ground coffee in my
mouth bro I wouldn't put in water I had
no time for that it was bitter as hell
bro I just did it for the caffeine
yeah you're close bro
yeah but coffee's amazing he's just a
hater black coffee especially with sugar
yes sir I know what about you
do you even know who Dickens is I have
no idea who Dickens is though
hey bro the only thing I actually read
is like
and maybe some other stuff
TNA buttercup
uh I don't know if that's too personal
okay well it's probably gonna be too
personal but but sometimes like Rami
really makes an active effort to smile
for us like sometimes
I have this feeling that he didn't
necessarily have the greatest day or is
not always in in the mood but actively
forces himself to be a friend bro let me
answer this for a while at least uh I at
least appreciate it
genuinely like he genuinely if he's
smiling he's genuinely smiling and if
he's not smiling he's genuinely not
smiling because
this man he wears his emotion like right
there
for the most part
Oxford Quran a good translation I've
tried reading it keyword tried and the
English is just a little bit tough and
for me I read books that have very
difficult English like if you read any
of his works and translations
but the thing is and on her Bro you've
read some some of imam's work right it's
not easy bro but when it comes to
English translations of the Quran you
want to read something that's very
easily palatable so I actually recommend
that this is not sponsored by the way
the clear Quran but Dr Mustafa khatab
who we've actually had on the podcast
and alhamdulillah this is I think the
other two brothers recommend that too
uh just a few more and then we'll be
done oh no you want to read out this one
is probably the jokester out of you guys
Romeo probably used to cut trees I
already Escape
I'm here probably doesn't like sushi
what is it with me bro I
can't speak for you man
but I can speak for myself man I used to
love cutting up some trees on uh
RuneScape I had level 99 on fire making
and level 99 on woodcutting I have no
idea what you're talking about bro I
never played RuneScape I I never played
a day in my life but I need to go grab
my charger so just bring me down for a
second I'll be back I got you wrong and
it's fired the funniest one
Allah knows best bro
next
Romy is the kind of guy I pray I marry
someone like him
this is Rami right now this is this is
Rami so
nothing
he's got nothing to offer no no no no no
make it uh and let me use you for your
sister yeah Miller make it easy let's
let's stop it on me and he's gonna say
Mel I'll give you something better than
me
what do you think about this comment
romy's the kind of guy I pray I marry
someone like him
may Allah give you better than me
I mean bro
uh
Anna looks like he has an interesting
life but it's private
you are correct
not wrong about that one
romy's probably a hopeless romantic not
anymore I think I used to be
I'm a hopeful romantic alhamdulillah
hopefully I know was probably a bully in
school
come on man we addressed this yeah we
did this photo all right that's it
that's it for today
all right my laptop is not charging at
all one second oh
no what part of India are you from
Hindu 3000
don't say that on the podcast bro that
was my no I'm not saying it like oh like
this is it no but that was my my
gamertag on uh Call of Duty at one point
there was
yeah
slingshot 509 that was great slingshot
bro how is being a Muslim as a Reaver
how how has your experience been so far
in the last couple weeks or months
comment Down Below on the live chat we
haven't heard back from you we're very
interested in
and uh that we're not going to address
this
she's not wrong
yeah
but uh our attorney has advised us not
to discuss that
for the sake of the channel yo
yeah
the assumption is crazy
yeah some people I remember slingshots
subhanallah
the newer The nurbi Shining obviously
great podcast
did he come back honestly yeah I mean he
just bro he just made an appearance bro
yo remember when um
mashallah it's very great to see people
of different Origins together
he created us in different ethnicities
and backgrounds so that we can get to
know each other
[Music]
all right he says it's great I'm getting
through Ramadan may Allah bless you and
make it easy for you man Ramadan is a
blessed time and it's amazing that you
know you accepted Islam early enough for
you to experience it this year
we should get you on the stream a
slingshot we'll get you on the stream
one day slingshot we got to get you on
the stream bro this time for real no
more technical issues
let's see around me bro feel free to put
on any last last ones and do any of you
have ADHD yes
when we do podcasts I'll be doing like
the most randomized comments but yeah my
ADHD is not as bad as this
I don't know what that means bro yeah me
neither I just got an aneurysm reading
that
yeah like Pokemon
I mean Allah bless you as well
took a shout out on camera he did it on
our stream live but he didn't put on his
camera yeah yeah
um Place Loki given goofy uh oh vile
Vibes no cop 100 no click bait PS5 Ultra
wide 8K what
this is what happens
no this is when YouTube you know with
the terms and conditions we gotta talk
like this bro figure the point across
that's funny that's true though
inshallah the three muslims.com
launching for unfiltered content soon
inshallah
Bengali everyone in London London are
you from London London any new guests
coming soon Rami
um new I don't know about that I don't
really have anyone new in mind but I did
want to bring some uh people we've had
in the past back on inshallah we'll see
we gotta remaster the old videos that we
had yeah yeah yeah 100 100 but
um okay let's let's wrap up the stream
shallow we'll take a few more comments
it's a new number yeah that's crazy yeah
but yeah I prayed for you from the past
news but you didn't read my comment
may Allah bless you for praying for me
may Allah forgive me for not having any
idea what you're talking about
and may Allah sincerely
reward you because I genuinely I mean it
bro I was very I think it was from your
ground your gramps I think so bro I
think so so I'm just gonna assume that
yeah
I would say to avoid watch anime due to
the amount of Haram that's exposed in it
example the music uh the women are
coming out et cetera yeah yeah
that would go for it I would go for any
TV show or movie in existence yeah yeah
yeah very true yeah but I'm going to be
honest once the most productive I've
been in my life I have I just I don't
watch TV I don't play video games I
don't watch it oh yeah I don't watch any
of that stuff I don't do any of that I
literally I just work alhamdulillah I
literally watched Daniel naroditski Jim
Daniel neridisky play chess like all day
whenever I have time I put up a video
concepts for you guys yeah messages
we're actually trying to do a channel
refresh right now we're in the process
inshallah so in the message us some
Concepts and
inshallah
three more comments yeah DMS on IG on
the three Muslims yes first one bring on
lucidan inshallah he's our next guest
coming soon inshallah within uh two
months three months we'll see
okay two more comments
I'm trying to make sure that you click
on Nick account
there's a lot of comments now
oh slingshot Road do you want to see me
now slingshot bro we got if there soon I
don't know if we're going to be able to
you know we'll give it we'll give him
we'll give him we'll give him five
minutes max yeah listen slingshot bro
five minutes or you're gonna have to
change your name bro you can't be a
slingshot of being snail paced yeah it's
not gonna work out
so five minutes you gotta you have to
give us a place to contact you if you're
putting an email don't put the whole
thing in one comment just put the
everything before that and then in a
different comment everything after that
if you could do that inshallah you can
come on the street
um
well but now I can I can join your
Discord okay join our Discord inshall
I'll be waiting for you
Loki actually haven't been on the
Discord in Forever
I have some articles and stuff I don't
know where to share the benefit of um
should I show first to work
is there any websites I can shoot I
don't know what you're referring to
yeah it's like the law of diminishing
marginal utility again all over again
like what are the articles about you
know
slingshot right or is in session
you know you know I'm waiting for you
Discord Lincoln Link in description yo
Rami we need to end it off
with a good reminder inshallah inshallah
you actually right absolutely right any
bearded beer growing tips we've spoken
about this many times bro but
uh just don't touch it sometimes you
just let it grow you can use a brush to
like stimulate the skin underneath get
more blood flow to it
but that's pretty much it you know let
let your genetics run their course
yeah
by the way what are your madahib or
y'all follow your local sheriffs I I
follow my my sheikhila but I I am trying
to learn uh
a little deeper before I can clean that
I'm one of the other
all right there's four minutes left yeah
um slingshot I don't see you man you
gotta gotta make an appearance oh there
do you want to do it on Discord Jordan
just join the Discord inshallah and then
um well we'll join the Discord he'll
send you the link
do we have verification on Discord I
have no idea bro I don't even use
Discord oh me neither it's okay we'll
see inshallah if not today then then we
can do next time
inshallah you guys got the hell areas no
cap Mega drip
I'll do like these bro what's what is
this man
I don't know what to say man we don't
know if you're like you're like you're
like hyping us up or you're making fun
what is the race
charisma
we got the negative words
no no we don't have a negative it is
beard Haram or Sunnah whoa it's
definitely not Haram what are you
talking about
look at the hater for the dean bro
getting offended I love that I love
about it that was a pretty out of pocket
question I'm not gonna lie yeah yeah but
I didn't realize that though yeah it's
okay slingshot if you can't make it
that's that's this right here that's a
lot of the real even the reasons a lot
bro Allah giving you the risk Islamic
race
sister
God bless you AED you are from the UAE
AED you were from the UAE I like that
they didn't sleep
oh oh he getting mad bro he getting mad
oh
moment
why are you why are you typing it so it
is what okay so I
there's a difference oh okay yeah yeah
there's a difference of opinion
it's not it's not a Sunnah to shave the
beard right the Sunnah is not to shave
your beard right the prophet saws would
have had to encourage shaving the beard
for it to be a Sunnah or if he would
have had to done it many times that's
not the case the Sunnah is to keep your
beard to keep it you know grown and long
and there are different rulings on it
but what some Scholars say and this is
the opinion that I follow is that Allah
will not actually punish you for for
like trimming your beard or anything
like that shaving in particular I'm not
gonna answer because I don't know uh you
should go ask a scholar but uh
yeah I don't have the confidence to
answer I don't know just trimming is
okay you're not a lot won't punish you
for it that's it I don't know about
shaving
yeah so if you guys then you don't have
to worry
all right I um I don't know if he's
gonna do a show today
yeah it's okay
I mean next time
next time there will be no next time
all right
all right so I was just looking at the
comments with that being said to show
that we're gonna go ahead and wrap it up
but before we wrap it up as Angel
mentioned inshallah we should give a
good reminder
for which I need a second to think
unless you guys have something on the
top of your head
um
actually
go ahead go for it okay
everything is very simple
life is very simple
it's us we're the ones that are
complicating it uh if we just put our
attention and our energy where it needs
to be if we focus on Allah we focus on
getting closer to Allah and then we
understand okay what else is
what's my uh Mission what what is it
that I have to do like what
responsibility do I have right now do I
have to provide for my family okay do
that instead of trying to think and like
over complicating just do that and then
when you have extra free time spend time
with your family and stuff like this do
other little things but uh there's
really no need to complicate things life
can be very very simple
and it's yeah it's that's my reminder
that's beautiful very beautiful I have
something very short inshallah and it's
just that knowledge is everything
perspective is everything
you know
imagine your life without Islam
completely or you would be a completely
different person now imagine your life
if you knew so much more islamically you
would be a completely different person
as long as you're valid you know
validate that knowledge and accept it so
people underestimate how important it is
to learn Islam when it's an obligation
so just adding on to what angel said
also just learn Islam everything is
simple
just learn Islam things will become more
clear inshallah
my uh my reminder is gonna be something
that I'm personally working on right now
and it's speed
so just the time between when you set
out to do something as a Muslim or if
you're watching this is a non-muslim
versus you actually doing it
if it's delayed well you don't got speed
you'll do it quickly then you go
slingshots here yeah he's in the he's in
the no send him the link
we get to see him
okay gender roof I mean face revealed
I don't know if he's a he's a brother or
sister
sister slingshot please correct uh
observe correct hijab not gonna say that
twice wait sister
Mr bro
slingshot
or are you slingshot
waiting for you
that's all they talk on on Tick Tock
every time someone's live they're like
you'll rise to the person rise that
person
yeah I got PTSD when they said that
made me feel like I was back on tick
tock
drink protein
okay I think they're gonna join
because they accepted my friend request
I'm also going to message them
you said they
yeah I said they they like there's more
than one slingshot
they like I don't know if it's if it's a
boy or a girl
oh you don't know the gender yeah
I would be happy to assume but I need
more to go off of than slingshot
yeah you're for real bro for real the
legend though yeah oh yo he's joining
wait wait
wait
the Moment of Truth there you go
[Music]
most anticipated guest
how you doing bro
yo slingshot bro I think your Wi-Fi is
busted yeah it's kind of hard to hear
you and it's a buddy slingshot how old
are you bro
I mean how young are you
thank you
that's that's it bro you heard it here
first
it's hard to hear you bro
he's muted bro that's why
no he just muted himself
let's mute it again
slingshot bro rise
what a martial law a boy
ah yo kill me bro slingshot don't kill
me bro tell us man how's this Landing
for you how's the how's life as a river
now
can you hear me
and barely bro to be honest it sounds
like you're whispering in my ear yeah
slingshot this is not ASMR bro
[Laughter]
so these comments are ruthless
slingshots I'll give you a call I'll
give you a call on Discord okay yeah
guys chill with these comments
I'm gonna call you
thank you
bro I'm dead
[Laughter]
I'm rolling
this wi-fi is fasting for a moment call
him up yeah yeah call him up I got him
I'm calling him slingshot can you answer
put your phone closer like this so you
can see it slingshot I'm giving you a
call can you answer
I think he's using his phone bro
probably but he should get he should be
getting this
I think he's gonna answer
yeah
for
eign bro
so it's better not to say that but
someone was definitely interfering bro
with the connection
but what a beautiful brother
honestly
bro I'm crying bro I'm Nigerian what
does that have to do with anything
what straight out of Zambia what
Abbas
Zambia or Gambia
chunks for Real come on Manchester is a
YouTuber right yeah
is this new
no
stock for all uh
all right uh yeah I don't think we're
gonna be able to get them today uh we
tried we got very close alhamdulillah
but I'll give him bro imagine we fly out
to him meet him in person and we titled
the podcast the legend of slingshot
that'd be sick man and we drop it when
we have a million Subs no less nobody
knows except those didn't know
very nice
that's it that's it we're done we're
done no more getting shot on the podcast
would be nice actually
no he's calling me
okay okay put it on speaker
hello
can you hear me
hey slingshot slam bro how you doing
I'm doing good that's good you're on mic
right now is that okay
all right all right uh firstly slingshot
I love you do you know that
yeah thank you thank you of course of
course so are you okay sharing your your
full name or not your full name your
first name or do you want us to call
your swing shot
thank you
pardon me
I need to kill him
no I think he's talking to someone
yeah
Toba or cobra October who's making Toba
no no no
um
bro ask him ask him about how life is
now as a reboot slingshot how's life as
a revert
Ramadan
that's right surviving
I surviving that's good man that's
always good Allah is with us man and
Allah will reward you for for all your
fast alhamdulillah it's difficult in the
first year and the first week in the
first few days but it's going to get
easier as you go okay
and we're here for you man you got the
whole t3m uh family here alhamdulillah
if you need anything we're here for you
my brother I'm very very glad you can
make it online with us today
do you have a message for the people
[Music]
pardon me
there's a lot of the way
beautiful how do you may I love bless
you immensely
I uh we have to go break our fast soon
so we're gonna get going but hopefully
inshallah ask him ask him how his family
is uh handling him becoming
uh anho wants to know how your family's
uh handling you becoming a Reaver and
accepting a snap
all right watch this video hi baby all
right inshallah let's let's connect have
your Discord now so let's connect
offline and we'll talk a little bit okay
I don't know how to ask him if there's
any duas that he wants us to make for
him are there any duas that you want us
to make for you is there anything you
want us to ask God for you
Muslim okay
hi baby happy we will
keep us all steadfast on Islam keep us
all Muslim and grant us the highest
levels of Heaven
I mean
all right
slingshot I love you brother inshallah
we'll talk soon okay
all right take care of yourself bye
yo no way no way
someone oh he Reverend me it's been a
year
no way it was last May I thought it was
like fall
I think I know I think no I think that
uh
someone's got the timeline messed up
yeah someone wrote five why did you say
may Allah forgive the shirt thing
because I was gonna say may Allah
causing the interference with the
disruption with the connection
because I don't know if you guys know
but jyn can interfere with that but I
didn't know if it was allowed to say may
Allah forgive the shading
does that satisfy you
gold
man this ended up it was it was great
and um yeah we all love you for the sake
of Allah we hope you all enjoyed this uh
I don't know what this was but it was a
great time I had fun
um if y'all want some more of this if
y'all wanna see a little twist on this
as well we include more Islamic
knowledge we even include a calling show
but we're bringing y'all into this with
us
the more engaging more interactive
please let us know in the comments down
below and with that being said around me
please